u
important à Longueuil tout comme
le logement abordable, la
destruction du patrimoine,
environnement, transport en
commun. Par compte, où tous les
candidats s'entend, c'est le
besoin d'assainir les relations
ici à l'hôtel de ville.
Voici un petit tour d'horizon.
♪ ♪ ♪
- On est très gâté en élections
cette année.
- Les élections fédérales
lui ont fait de l'ombre.
- Est-ce qu'on peut compter
sur votre appui le 7 novembre?
- Oui, sûrement, oui.
C'est le 27...?
- C'est le 7 novembre.
- Mais la campagne municipale
est bel et bien commencée.
- Moi, je rencontre les citoyens
depuis le mois de juin,
un par un, porte par porte.
- Vous savez que c'est
au municipal que la majorité
des décisions qu'on prend
ont beaucoup d'impact?
Je pense qu'on a fait
l'actualité un petit peu trop.
- La candidate Josée Latendresse
veut aussi en finir
avec les controverses.
- C'est décevant, effectivement.
- Elle se représente après avoir
perdu par quelque centaines
de voix en 2017.
JOSÉE LATENDRESSE, candidate
à la mairie de Longueuil
- Quand on fait les choses
une deuxième fois,
habituellement, on fait mieux.
Dans les dernières années,
on a beaucoup vu un "top down".
Ce n'est plus comme ça
qu'on fait de la politique.
On a beaucoup vu de la politique
partisane. On ne travaille plus
comme ça.
- Jacques Létourneau, candidat
à la mairie de Longueuil.
- L'ancien président de la CSN,
lui, a choisi la continuité.
Il se présente pour Action
JEAN-MARC LÉVEILLÉ, candidat
à la mairie de Longueuil
- C'est quelqu'un qui a quand
même cinq ans d'expérience
sur le marché du travail
qui aspire à gérer 800 millions
de budget.
- Anciennement à la tête
de l'Orchestre symphonique
de Longueuil, gestionnaire
et entrepreneur de carrière,
il se lance en politique
avec le parti Longueuil Citoyen,
le parti de l'opposition.
- C'est le temps qu'on ait des
gestionnaires qui s'intéressent
à gérer les affaires publiques.
- Son plus grand défi :
se faire connaître.
- Actuellement, ce qui est
en train de me préoccuper, là,
c'est que c'est les médias
montréalais qui vont décider
qui sont les candidats pour
D'où l'importance de faire
campagne jusqu'à la fin.